let's take a look  science has become so arrogant in its  premise that it has all the answers it  sounds like something peterson would say  but i think the whole point of the game  here  is it's difficult to tell i'm gonna go  with  this is  i believe this is deepak chopra all  right i'm going to click on the answer  let's take a look  what happens is that there are  fundamentalists in science that is  absolutely wrong science's quest is to  try to sort out to tease out those bits  that we've done science has become so  arrogant in its um in its premise that  it has all the answers in a mechanistic  approach  that it has whilst it has gotten rid of  lots of things like polio and malaria  and tuberculosis in many parts of the  world  we are now seeing the emergence of  modern epidemics that are a result of  some of the things that have come about  through science there it is folks it was  deepak chopra okay so that's how the  game works